this mystery involves a mystical
creature that really exists
it's called a narwhal and it lives in an
icy kingdom in the northern Arctic
a long time ago people thought its long
tusks was a prize with magical powers
just like that of a unicorn okay in
truth this tusks can't do real magic but
if not magic then what does it do it's
been a mystery through the ages some
detectives thought it was a weapon
others thought it might help attract
Timmy
but no one knew for sure until this
dentist stepped up to solve the case yep
Martin louia is a dentist really good
sleuths have all sorts of skills like
filling cavities and being a dentist
really came in handy on this case
because the narwhals horn is actually a
tooth it's a single tooth that's grown
really really long like in some cases
three meters long or more than nine feet
but Martin still had to do a lot of
detective work to discover what the
narwhal to is used for I mean it's not
like you can chew at that thing or bite
into an apple with it Martin spent years
studying the narwhal and used a lot of
high-tech spy tools to figure out what
the tooth was used for
and he solved the mystery
it seems this supersize tusk is sort of
a secret instrument that can measure all
sorts of things like temperature and
water pressure you know how your teeth
sometimes ate when you bite into
something frozen well this big tusk
may let the narwhal know when the water
is really cold or salty it may even
detect the presence of fish the narwhal
likes to eat fries huh and what looks
like aggressive Narwhal swordsplay
well Martin thinks this might actually
be too narwhals helping each other keep
their teeth clean okay it looks like a
pretty strange way to brush your teeth
but animals are mysterious creatures
with strange ways of doing things that
we dentists detectives have to keep
gathering clues to solve these tough
cases